[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: Welcome to
this episode of Click
to Deploy, a series
where we show you
how easy it is to deploy
solutions from the Google Cloud
Marketplace.
In this episode,
we'll be reviewing
how to set up a WordPress
website via the Cloud
Marketplace.
In case you're
unfamiliar, WordPress
is a free open source
content management system
used to build custom websites.
Let's start by searching for
WordPress in the Marketplace.
Since WordPress is
open source, you'll
see that we have a few
different deployment
options from different vendors.
Each deployment may be deployed
with different operating
systems, security
patches, or server shapes.
For this demo, we'll choose the
Google Click to Deploy Virtual
Machines option.
The landing page will
display information
about the deployment,
pricing, and support.
The pricing information
displays a high-level estimate
of charges.
Once deployment
options are picked,
we'll receive a more
detailed breakdown.
It's important to review
the additional details
to understand the technical
details for the deployment.
We can see that a
single VM will be
deployed on Compute
Engine running the Debian
OS at version 9.13.
We can also see all
of the packages that
will be installed on the VM.
Let's begin the launch.
Let's pick a deployment
name end zone.
In this case, I'll go with
the default zone, US East 4b.
I'll also stick with
the default machine
type, which is an E2 Small.
The machine type chosen
should correspond
with how much traffic load you
are expecting on your WordPress
site.
We'll choose an email
address that we'll
use for our PHP admin account.
We'll also stick
with all the default
storage and networking options.
Lastly, let's allow
source traffic
from the internet via
both HTTP and HTTPS.
Before you deploy, you can
see your final estimate
of charges for the specific
options you choose to deploy.
By clicking Details, you can
see how these costs break down.
We'll launch and give our
deployment a minute to spin up.
The next page will show
us all the information
about our specific deployment.
Clicking the site address will
display our default WordPress
website.
We're provided all of the
admin connectivity and login
information for both
WordPress and MySQL.
We're also given the
ability to SSH directly
into our WordPress server.
You'll also see that we're
given some suggested next steps,
like changing
temporary passwords
and assigning a static
public IP address.
Let's log in as the WordPress
admin and change the password.
There we go.
After we change MySQL
passwords, we're
ready to start customizing
our WordPress site
and configure a domain.
If you enjoyed this video,
please subscribe and hit
the Like button below.
We encourage you to check
out the GCP marketplace
and deploy the
solution on your own.
Thanks for watching.